we had a truly incredible year here at
the Rubin report so we wanted to end
2017 with some of my favorite moments
over the last 12 months your support is
what makes this show happen and I hope
you are as proud of the conversations
we've had as I am when I look at people
talk about intersectionality and and all
you know this whole identity politics
thing what I see is taking the human
being
magnifying a biological attribute and
then putting them aside putting them in
a corner as victims of oppression and in
a way I feel sorry for them I happen to
be black and I happen to be a woman and
I happen to be a minority in the United
States
I even happened to be an apostate so
talk about intersectionality yeah but
none of that defines me as Who I am I'm
more than all of that and I most
certainly don't see myself as a victim
and knowing people who grew up in Africa
who grew up in Muslim countries you
probably know also some gay people who
had to struggle and go through adversity
I think when you come out of it you come
out as a proud survivor there is a
tendency for people I think especially
religious people to identify so strongly
with their ideas of the religious ideas
that they think that to criticize there
are their religious ideas to criticize
their beliefs is tantamount to insulting
them personally it's tantamount to
saying you've got an ugly face and this
is so wrong and it's so so retrograde
because you the ideas are there to be
criticized you must be able to defend
your ideas if they're any good then you
should say I believe this because I
believe this because so and so because x
y&z you you you cannot just just shout
as I oh you've insulted me you've you've
mortally offended me by criticizing my
ideas
I again to quote Christopher Hitchens he
said you're offended by what I've just
said I'm still waiting to hear your
point even in a day you'll see that you
have choices in front of you and
sometimes you don't know what to do life
is suffering that's true
there's malevolence that's true meaning
is the antidote to that yes and it's not
it's not some kind of fragile
epiphenomena it's the deepest thing so
and we'll need to know that it's so
important to know that even when you're
disagreeing with someone try your best
even no matter how you how much you
disagree with them and and and and
everything that they're saying give them
leave them with a door open right to
save some face to maybe realize that
part of what they were thinking there is
a misstep there because when you put
someone in a corner although you're only
really confirming or all you're really
doing is locking them down in their
belief right I I've been there right
when in in the past if I've been talking
to someone and they hit me with
something that proves like something I
previously thought was wrong it almost
feels like I'm being like attacked or
like I'm being told I'm stupid and it's
not a great feeling so when you're
arguing with someone right if the real
intent is is to to hopefully promote
truth right hopefully promote the right
thought hopefully then you're leaving
the door open for them the pace of
progress isn't what people expect I did
not expect to have tremendous progress I
was not responding to them as I did it
with the thought that they were going to
turn around in that instant but I did
think it might plant a seed and that
they would come around over the course
of days or hours as if they had
interactions that didn't line up with
the narrative that they've been sold
that they would be forced to think
consciously about what explains the fact
that this person that we've been told is
a vile transparent racist doesn't sound
like one and you know I think when I
watched that video which I don't love
doing but when I watch that video right
I see hints of that and then I had
interactions later in the day where I
also saw him set
but there is also this overwhelming
gravity coming from the argument that
describes itself as pro equity that that
erases progress so even when you
partially reach somebody they get reeled
back in so quickly the developing world
thinks that the West would be crazy to
give up on itself yes it's got more
entertaining dances or better food or in
some rich and storied history and great
narratives and art but the fact of the
matter is is that the West has probably
more attraction from fur for those
people than any other place we are
amplifier is what distinguishes us we
have done everything more powerfully
than every other group and so it's not
whether or not what we're doing is right
or wrong because every culture does
right and wrong but our amplifier is
bigger so you know if you plug in a
Stratocaster to a huge stack built for a
stadium and you make a mistake I
guarantee you they're gonna hear three
counties over around the other hand if
you play a fantastic solo that's there
too and I don't understand how when did
we give up on the West we live in a
country that's got three hundred and
thirty million people roughly eight to
ten percent of them believe Elvis is
still alive almost half of them believe
you've seen Elvis a letter you'll get it
obviously there's racism there are
individuals who don't like other people
because of their race no question about
it
but are there corporations they have a
policy of not hiring anybody or are
there governmental agencies have a
policy not hiring anybody the answer is
no if you can tell me the company IBM
Apple that has a policy of not hiring
black people tell me or brown people
tell me who with that company is and we
can deal with it I don't know what
people mean when they talk about
institutional racism if this were the
50s I would know what you're talking
about when there was what there was
segregation that was legal segregation
in the south when you couldn't marry
somebody outside your race in certain
states but that is no longer the case
right now the racism that people talk
about right now in my opinion is
individual stuff where some individual
doesn't like you or some individuals
don't like you but is it something that
is anything akin to what we experienced
in the 50s in the 60s absolutely not and
I think it's insulting to people who
have fought hard
and died in the 50s and the 60s to get
us to this point to act like things are
just the same yeah when you have people
like Eric Holder saying as he did when
he was AG we now have precious racism
which he said was every bit as bad as
the old racism what the hell are you
talking about let me just ask you quite
you raised the child right and I'm so I
just want to ask you how many times do
you feel roughly you told her say thank
you 10,000 a little bit nudge him a
little bit please child I told I told my
son's at each of them at least 10,000
times they're like say thank you if they
were inherently good they would first of
all never have to be told the first it's
not certainly not many other times not
black and white it's all they're all
good or they're all evil no no no no but
don't say we could learn that we have
this great we built-in sense do we then
why did the world state reposes are
filled why slavery universal rape
universal murder universal well we know
even this is rarer than than all of
these terrible lies but but it's been
changing and there's a reason for that
and the reason is reason now people can
be interested in whatever they like but
I also have the right to time I think
they're wasting their lives gender
pronouns all of this sort of thing these
this is there is by the way behind all
this something very strange I started to
notice there among all the fascinating
things about this one of the ones that
interests me most is why you get this
this this introduction to almost every
discussion as if we as human beings are
sort of solvable things I find this
fascinating most of the trans stuff is
you know identify that you're of the
wrong gender at an early stage by the
way I'm very suspicious about all that
but let's say in the case of somebody
actually does genuinely feel that they
are in the wrong body and so on that
there is this awful thing in it as in so
many other discussions at the moment of
and if you mix that you you'll be on
you'll be right mm-hmm
and I think no no no once you sort that
out you'll face all the same problems
everyone else faces in their lives and
maybe some new ones but this this is I
hear this in the race discussion in
America I hear it in the gay discussion
in America in in a whole set of them
it's as if it's as if if we get the
formula right I said I I just think this
is a fascinating mistake I don't think
we live our lives as solved or solvable
beings and and we are we are engaged it
seems to me in particular in this
society in America in this strange
attempt to sort of get it the my new shy
right and apart from being deeply
navel-gazing
it seems likely to me that that we may
be missing all the really important
things that are going on I have this
sort of haunting view always that we all
feel like we've really sorted out every
aspect of LGBTQI rights just as China
becomes the most important power in the
world like to go back to kill
mockingbird which now is getting banned
in the state of Mississippi because of
you know it's - it's an insanity or a
were like a book-burning air almost it's
named but it's a kill mockingbird
Atticus Finch puts Mayella Ewell on the
witness stand and he aggressively
questions whether or not she was raped
and as by virtue of that aggressive
questioning we find out that she made up
the allegation that she was raped by a
black man Tom Robinson the jury still
convicts him because that's the broken
system of southern jurisprudence in a
pre Civil Rights era but it's a powerful
moment because that's why we have an
adversarial system you don't
automatically assume that somebody is
telling the truth because of their race
or because of their gender and we have
so swung I believe from an era where a
black guy's automatically guilty in the
south because he's black to a black guys
telling the truth because he's a black
guy or a woman's not telling the truth
because she's a woman - a woman's
telling the truth because she's a woman
I think you have to look and this
crazy I can't believe they had to say
this not but I think you have to look at
the facts of every individual case I
think that rape happens I think it's
awful
but that doesn't mean that I think every
time a woman says she was raped it's
true I think that racism is awful it
shouldn't happen but that doesn't mean
that every time somebody says something
racist happened that you have to believe
it in York all all kind of all kinds of
people are they have the right to to
have their faces to have their full
identity without fear you have the
malicious a groups in York
Hezbollah WA has been sardonic Atilla
Hezbollah they you know they come up to
people with their faces with their
identities and you have the other side
the terrorists in our archives well they
act you know freely in the country but
for people like me you know I didn't
hurt anyone
I didn't you know treat anyone in a bad
way so why should I hide my my identity
I mean it's very important for me to
declare Who I am
because everyone has the right to
declare who they are and and and in what
they do believe in for me it's very
important to say that I am an atheist
because in my country everyone is
calling that we are Muslims we are
Sydney's we are Shia and we practice
what we want but for me it became in the
recent years very important to share my
thoughts you never really own freedom
David we only take care of freedom and
preserve it to the next generation and I
am doing my part as an American as a
brave American and the home of the brave
to make sure I follow in the footsteps
of our founding fathers and do my part
as they entrusted me with that which
they have created I feel that it is my
duty to make sure to preserve it to pass
it to my children and their American
children and many generations to come
that's why we fight and I am so
fortunate that through this fight and it
is a fight for freedom for
for democracy for security for human
rights I am privileged to meet the most
amazing people that I would never
otherwise meet like sitting here with
you today and meet friends that have
become lifelong friends literally like
family to me that I would never have
otherwise met if it wasn't doing for
what I do so do I get depressed doing
what I do talking about terrorism and
national security of course I do I'm
human like everybody sometimes I cry
sometimes I'm completely depressed over
things that are happening sometimes I
hurt deeply by people who stab me in the
back or say bad things about me or even
reading my Wikipedia profile but what
keeps me so energized is the American
people and the American spirit knowing
that we are making a difference we are
growing we are changing our country we
are fighting we have a purpose so when
you and I died on our deathbed we can
look back and we can say I made a
difference
as we take our get this very special
take somebody show you this I'm going
nowhere so if you don't like my theme